الطلبه في باريس عنا الوقوف في البردي في
هذا الطابور الطويل لاجل الظفر بطرد
المعونه الغذائيه انها واحده من تداعيات
موجه الغلاء وما سببته الحرب في اوكرانيا
طالب في علم الاجتماع تاكله ميزانيته
المحدوده اصلا بسبب التضخم ولم يعد راتبه
كافيا لدفع الايجار وتسديد الفواتير حتى
ما عليه الارتجال للمعونه الغذائيه
من الوقت لتحضير العشاء لذلك اكتفي باكل
هذه الواجبه الجائزه هذا يساعدوني على
الاقتصاد في ميزانيه الاكل لدفع للجار سله
المعونه الغذائيه تمكني من توفير الاكل
حتى موعد توزيع الاعانه الغذائيه المقبل
الذي يعيش في غرفه لا تتجاوز مساحتها 10
امتار مربعه من المراجعه وتحضير واجباته
المنزليه على المائده مالا اليه وضع
الطلبه ليس بسبب ارتفاع نسبه التضخم وحسب
فالنقبات الطلابيه تلقي باللائمه كذلك على
سياسات التي انتهجتها الحكومه في تعاملها
مع شان الجامعي في السنوات الماضيه
في مقر الاتحاد الوطني لطلبه الفرنسيين
يشتكي ممثل الطلبه من وجود فجوه بينما
تقدمه الحكومه للطالب واحتياجاته الحقيقيه
ويستنقرون تراجع الدعم الحكوميه في عهد
الرئيس امانويل ماكرون مقارنه بسابقين
واقع تؤكده خلاصه مسح سنويا للاتحاد تفيد
بتراجع المساعدات المباشره للطلبه في
ولايه ماكرون الاولى بنسبه تفوق 55%
مقارنه بسلفه فرانس واولوند وبازياده من
واحد و20% مقارنه مع فتره حكم الرئيس
الاسبقي نيكولا سارزيزي
فقط اكثر في البلاد تخفض الحكومه بنسبه
55% المساعدات المباشره للطلبه مقارنه مع
ولايه فرانس واولاند نطالب بوضوح ان تؤخذ
بعين كبار حقيقه تدهور وضع المعيشي للطلاب
وان تتم الاستجابه لمطالبنا خصوصا اعاده
النظر في نظام اسناد المنح
الحكومه من جهتها تعتبر وان الوضع الذي
يعاني منه العديد من الطلبه غير مقبول
واعلن وزير التضامن بالاتفاق مع وزيره
التعليم العالي عن تخصيص عشره ملايين يورو
لتمويل المساعدات الغذائيه للطلبه واكد ان
هذه الخطوه سيصحبها عمل معمق لاصلاح نظام
المنح الدراسيه كما كشف عن تخصيص عشرات
الملايين من اليوروهات للجمعيات التي
تكافح سوء التغذيه في البلاد لطفي
المسعودي الجزيره باريس